the og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
hill plan show today we have a brilliant
conversation and we're talking about
something which i've actually never
spoken about before we are talking about
bitcoin and healthcare pretty wild so
make sure you stick around um now before
we do get into this um i do want to let
you know that it is sponsored by um
bitmex the og crypto derivatives
exchange they now actually have a spot
exchange for you to buy and sell your
crypto especially in a bear market with
this kind of volatility that we're
seeing you need a name that you can
trust and bitmex sets the standard for
reliability performance and transparency
and
of course has proven itself through
multiple market cycles and this has
stood the test of time so very important
and with all the volatility that we have
right now and they're actually giving
away um one million dollars in usd
prizes um to um anybody that gets
involved with the bitmex spot exchange
so all you have to do to enter is trade
the equivalent of 250
so if you do want to buy the dip it's
probably a good place to buy the dip
so you can actually grab some bitcoin
during the crash and um yeah try and
enter into that you can actually enter
up to 25 times and one lucky winner will
even receive a 500 000 in bitcoin so i'm
gonna leave the uh the description and
everything that you need the links and
everything like that in the description
below so take a look um and maybe try
yourself some bitcoin um up to five
hundred thousand and one million dollars
that's pretty cool
um okay guys so like i said we are
talking about bitcoin and healthcare
um money and therefore the central banks
really are at the center of everything
so i'm so excited today to bring on andy
schunover the ceo of crowdhealth let's
bring andy on andy welcome to the show
how you doing good thanks for having me
it's so good to have you um like i
mentioned this is a topic that i've
never spoken about before um i think you
know people throw out the term bitcoin
fixes this and often
it's quite cringy um but apparently
there's a way that bitcoin does help uh
the um the medical and healthcare system
um so
let's just start by you introducing
yourself um and explaining how you got
into healthcare and bitcoin
yeah sure so um i've been in healthcare
for about 15 years
started doing healthcare by called
remote patient monitoring so we had a
company that was monitoring folks with
chronic conditions out of their home so
if you had
diabetes let's say we would be
monitoring your glucometer and if your
blood sugar spiked then we'd say okay
something is going on here let's get
involved so we had a call center of lots
and lots of nurses who are watching that
information to try to keep you from
going into the hospital
sold that company back in 2014. um and
in the united states i know you're
abroad but in the united states
we have most of us have health insurance
through our company but since i sold my
company i didn't have health insurance
anymore so i thought that i could go to
healthcare.gov
which is a marketplace here that's
basically standardized by the government
to help people get health insurance and
so i went and got health insurance
from my wife and my two girls and it was
1200 bucks a month and it was an 8 000
deductible which means i'm paying 1200
bucks a month and then the first 8 000
of any of our health expenses so i'm a
good 20 what is that 22 grand in before
the health insurance company pays pays
anything
and uh i just had a bad bad experience
where my my little one was having
recurring ear infections and
the
doctor said she needed to get tubes in
her ears so he did that and the health
insurance came back and said they
weren't going to pay for it so the
surgery was eight thousand dollars it
was 15 minutes so eight thousand dollars
in 15 minutes i mean i kind of joked
that we would all love that hourly rate
right um
and so i was like at that point i was
like man screw this like if you're not
going to pay for my health care then um
i'm not i'm not interested in doing this
and so i've actually been uninsured for
the last
at least two years probably two and a
half years um and it's been been awesome
um been a free a pretty freeing thing i
i also joke that
over the last two years i've ditched
health insurance and i have bought
bitcoin which to me are two of the most
freeing things that you can do in in the
united states
that is so crazy i'm so excited to get
into this i just i can't believe the way
um the healthcare is in the u.s i've
been reading a lot about it i've been
asking um quite a lot of different
people because i've seen you we're gonna
have this conversation um and it really
it blows my mind because we complain
about it in the uk um but we can see a
doctor for free
we can see a doctor on the same day for
free we can get private medical cover
for 70 pounds
a month and that covers everything
there's no there's no like you know you
need to get in a car accident nearly die
pay 20 grand and then you get insured
and then you get cover it blows my mind
yeah yeah and i think that um
[Music]
it's one of those things where
you you can choose cost quality and time
that's kind of like the triangle that
you have to deal with right if you want
something that is low cost you're either
gonna have to pay a lot for it or you're
gonna have to wait a long time to get it
um
and you know here in the united states
it's you know pretty high quality very
high cost
but we can step in and and see you know
provider you know right away and you the
the rip against other plans you know
canada has a socialized system the uk
has a socialized system is that you know
it takes a while to get into see some of
those those specialists um and that's
sometimes the case and sometimes not the
case i mean i think the question more um
you know plainly is
do you want the government involved in
your health care right and you know i
talked to a lot of bitcoiners and most
of them say no i talked to other
bitcoiners and a lot of them are like
yeah well you know it's way way cheaper
so why not i mean i think you can make a
really good argument here that if you
don't want the government involved in
your dollar your money
then you probably don't and you really
truly want to be a a sovereign you know
individual then you probably should
wouldn't want the government being
involved in in choosing what you can or
cannot consume in terms of of healthcare
and so
go ahead i'm sorry no no go on so if you
want kind of the purest you know
sovereignty then what it should be is i
should be paying for health care
not through my taxes not through my
company but myself
um and being able to choose what i want
to
consume and what i don't want to consume
there's this kind of overarching
view at least through you know the left
and through pro-government folks is that
we're not smart enough to make decisions
about our own health care and so we need
others to tell us how to do it i just
don't believe that you know i don't
believe that that that should be the
case um and sure we should rely on
doctors to help us make decisions but
ultimately they should be you know our
decisions and not the government's
decisions on what what type of health
care we should be able to consume
yeah absolutely for those who are just
tuning in now um we're basically talking
about bitcoin and healthcare um and how
andy um
is uh he started this company called
crowdhealth and crowd health are
essentially um merging bitcoin and
healthcare together so we're going to
try to figure out whether uh bitcoin
truly fixes the healthcare system but
before we go into that i really want to
just sort of unpack like what is wrong
with the um with the healthcare system
but before that um you know you talk
about being that sovereign individual
i'm intrigued what is it about bitcoin
and that you're interested in you know
why didn't you think about making
something with um i don't know ethereum
or what other cryptocurrencies like why
did you want to mix healthcare with
bitcoin of all things
yeah and so you know one of the big ways
that health insurance works is that
i put my premiums in every month like i
said with me and my my family i was
putting 1200 in every month and i didn't
see it right it disappeared it went to
this black hole of health insurance land
and in essence what the health insurance
company does is they
have this big pool of of dollars you
know sitting in a bank account it's
called a risk pool so that if anybody
has a really big health event they'll be
able to use that risk pool to pay for
that health event
the problem with that
is that
that pool of dollars is melting you know
we had 9.1 percent inflation in the last
month that pool of capital is is going
down in terms of value and therefore to
replenish it you have to pay more into
that pool of capital and so with
healthcare not only do we have an
inflationary impact
that we're seeing especially over the
last six months we're also seeing a
systemic inflation
because of government regulation that
over the last three decades health care
prices has have gone you know through
the roof so we have these two
inflationary impacts on that pool of
capital that said hey hold on a second
here um if we can
pay for health care in a different way
we get rid of the systemic inflation if
we can hold that pool of capital in
bitcoin as opposed to dollars then you
get rid of the in the
money supply issues that that are
driving inflation you get rid of both of
those and you really can disrupt the way
that health care is being paid for in
this country and so that's why bitcoin
was so interesting to me and in fact i
was
talking to jimmy song who i know you
know many of the people watching this
he's a friend of mine i live in austin
and we were at lunch and i was telling
him about my fiat version of this and
he's like dude andy if you can do what
you're doing in the fiat and introduce
bitcoin into this you will have you know
a killer you know service because you're
getting rid of that money supply
inflation
and that's what really turned me on to
it so i got orange peeled by jimmy and
my business model is way way better
since i got to incorporate bitcoin
that's really cool we'll get into all of
that um so
but you know you talk about um the price
going up um you mentioned inflation um
but overall i just i just can't
attribute the medical uh system in the
u.s to inflation obviously so can you
break down for us you know why it's such
a mess i mean somebody just by the way
wrote in the comments now in france it's
only one euro and i know they have crazy
taxes there but you have crazy taxes
here in the us anyway yeah yeah um so
the reason why it's so screwed up in the
united states is
um the the buyers of health care
are health plans so they're the ones
that are ultimately paying
for your health care if i were to go and
slip and tear my acl
you know and i had health insurance the
health insurance company would be the
one that is paying for that health event
they have a contract with the local
hospital they have a a rate that has
been agreed upon they're the buyer okay
the seller of healthcare are big
hospital systems and so
we have this crazy thing in the united
states where if i put if i pay a
thousand dollars per month to the health
insurance company
they can only make 150 off of me in
profit and administrative costs okay and
so um so for them to make
their their profit generating you know
organizations and so for them to get
more profit the only way they can do
that
is to have my premium go up right so if
they wanted to make 10 percent more 165
dollars a month on me my premium would
have to go from a thousand to
eleven hundred and fifty dollars right
um so they're actually incentivized to
make more profit and therefore
incentivized to see my rate go up every
every month so the buyers of healthcare
are incentivized to see the price go up
the sellers of healthcare the hospital
systems they're the ones you know
providing the services
they clearly want the price to go up
they want to get paid more for their
service
and so it's just weird thing where it's
so perverse the buyers of healthcare and
the sellers of healthcare want the price
to go up and therefore
the price is going to go up
you know it's it's not that hard to
understand when you kind of understand
the
true incentives of these organizations
everybody wants the price to go up and
therefore that's what happens
unfortunately
and i think as well um you know you talk
about these incentives but there's a lot
of talk about corruption in the uh
medical industry um i'm interested um to
hear your take on that
yeah there is i would say it's probably
five percent i mean it's not a lot i
mean there's corruption out there um i i
generally think that 95 of doctors who
are the ones who are ultimately kind of
saying hey this is what i with the
medical procedure i want you to to to do
to to cure you whether it be an injury
or an illness they then have to go to
the health plan and say please health
plan will you allow me to perform
surgery on andy because he tore his acl
that health plan then can say yes
they'll pay for it or no they won't pay
for it and so um
you know there there is a little bit of
corruption there it's not a ton it's
it's probably five maybe ten percent of
the total cost in in the country but it
is it's not one that that massively
moves the needle one way or the other
but i think in that example the the
important part of that is
it's not your doctor ultimately making
the decision it's the health plan
ultimately making the decision right and
in the nhs or if you're in medicare or
in medicaid or whatever it is the
government ultimately making the
decision whether or not they're going to
pay for that service and that's one
where i was like hey let's take
the big health insurance plan let's take
the government out of this and let it be
between you and your doctor and you all
can decide you know what you want to pay
for or not pay for for your your health
what about
monopolies in the healthcare industry um
what what's going on there that could
potentially you know be pushing these
prices up
yeah so i i live in austin um we have
two big health systems in austin it's
called st david's an ascension
and if you think about united healthcare
or one of the other big health insurance
providers coming to austin
they have to have those two health
systems because nobody's going to choose
united health care if they don't have
both of them they want access to all of
those resources and so
you you basically have a duopoly in
austin negotiating against united
healthcare and so even if united wanted
to negotiate against these two hospital
systems they can't
you know i i make a claim and i truly
believe this that i have more
negotiating power with the local
hospital system than unitedhealthcare
does which is i think the seventh
largest company by revenue on the planet
you know and so that's one of the
benefits of me buying my care as opposed
to united i have more negotiating power
than united healthcare does in getting a
really good price for my for my service
and and that's one of the challenges
that we we see with our current system
is you've got somebody who's supposed to
negotiate on our behalf
who is not negotiating on their behalf
because they don't want to and they
don't they can't really negotiate on
their behalf because they're negotiating
against the new duopoly
you have very concentrated power on both
sides which ultimately leads to just
higher prices and that's what's really
screwed up our system
so what is crowd health how are you
trying to basically change that so
crowd is basically an alternative option
for people in the u.s yeah
you know so
when i um had that situation with my
daughter and the the health plan said
that they they wouldn't it was medically
unnecessary and so they wouldn't cover
it i
i spent the next two years um put coming
together putting together some tools
that said hey if i wanted to live
outside the health insurance space if i
wanted to make my own
sovereign choices about what happens
with me and my family's health care then
i got to put you know i got to figure
out how to do this right so we put
together some tools that allow us to to
operate effectively outside of of health
insurance and so you know we have
unlimited access to virtual
primary care physicians i could go on
today i can talk to a primary care
physician about whatever's going on with
me
i pay a certain amount per month no
incremental cost doing that really
inexpensive which is awesome right
i have access to really low cost
prescription drugs which is great
i take out the insurance plan
and what they call the pharmacy benefit
manager
here in the united states which is the
two primary
drivers of cost and i can go almost
directly to the drug companies and get
much better pricing than united
healthcare can get even
and then i have this community of people
that i'm a part of so if i have a really
big health expense
then these community of people can pitch
in to andy's health expense so if i tour
my acl um the health plan generally
would be paying like twenty thousand
dollars twenty to twenty two thousand
dollars for that acl
i can pay in cash twelve thousand
dollars um for that same
um surgery so what united healthcare
will pay for twenty two thousand i can
pay twelve thousand dollars in cash um
so then the question is like how do i
get cash to pay for that not a lot of
people have twelve thousand dollars
hanging around so in crowd health what
happens is we got a community of people
i pay the first 500 crowd health goes
out and crowd funds the remaining 11 500
and i we do that we've done that on in
an average of three days
so within three days you can get the
remaining 11 500 to pay for your your
acl
replacement or your acl repair
so we're saving you a ton of money
you're paying for it in cash
and it's just all around a better system
to be able to to do that
so how are you able to access um cheaper
surgeries yeah
um and cheaper prescriptions yeah so
let's let's talk about the acl um yeah
if you got paid by a health plan you'd
get paid 22 000 but you have to bill for
that so um i was talking to one
orthopedic surgeon he's got eight
billers for every doctor
right so those eight billers are costly
they're expensive
they also have to use their
the software that they use is the one
that actually builds it and that
software takes another six or ten
percent
plus the the the doctor spends about 30
percent of his time
dealing with health insurance
so if he could get that 30 percent back
doing
surgeries he can make a lot more money
yeah plus they don't get paid by the
health plan for 60 to 120 days
i'm paying for that that on the day of
the surgery so all of these things the
doctors look at this and say
wow like i want to get paid in cash
on the day of of the surgery
and i will give you a significant
reduction
in in doing that so for all those
reasons doctors
when i talk to them are the most excited
about this because they get rid of all
of this administrative burden
um and get paid in cash on the day of
the surgery which they love so that's
the core of how we're able to do this is
pay doctors in cash on the day of the
surgery and ultimately we'll pay them in
bitcoin via lightning on the day of the
surgery and my friction goes down even
even more you know we've done that
before have you done that i don't know
not yet but it's version two of what
we're trying to do because you know
we're telling all the doctors that we're
working with hey can we pay you in
bitcoin um and and ultimately they're
gonna start saying yes and we're gonna
start doing it over
with bitcoin so it'll be it'll be fun
once we make that that stat
oh i believe it um that's that's only 12
months away for sure um
that's that's really interesting um so
you know you talk about uh you putting
down the first 500
um and then um you know you're gonna
you're basically gonna
raise i guess 11 500. so where are you
getting that money from yeah so um all
of our members put in about 175 bucks a
month every month into an account the
count is theirs
and then when we
try to crowdfund for that 11 500
crowd health will go to all those people
and say hey you have 500 bucks in your
account you know will you use 50 of it
to help andy with his torn acl and then
you have the dollars 50 bucks right
right you don't ask for much no it's on
average it's been about 50 bucks
something per person so if you have four
people in your your you know your family
it's more than that but it's on average
about 50 bucks
so you have 500 in your account that you
put in right i'm asking you to use 50 of
it to help andy
and
if you say yes then i transfer 50 from
your account to andy's account if you
say no then i move on to the next person
so um you know then the question is like
okay so why would i help andy you know
with his torn acl it's not like
childhood leukemia or something that's
like tugs at your heart we've got an
internal system that says um you know
leia has been asked ten times and she
said no nine out of the ten times so
leia is not a very good member of the
community and so when leia asks for um
others to crowdfund her health event we
tell her we say it's leia you're not in
the united states but if you were um
leia is from x state she has a torn acl
she has a
a reputation score of 1 out of 10 which
means she's not a very good member of
the community and she's trying to raise
11 500
the probability that leia gets i'm
picking on you but you know what i'm
saying the probability
that leia gets gets crowdfunded is
really really low because you haven't
been a good member of the community so
there's a reciprocity engine that
generates people saying yes and wanting
to to give to the community but you can
say no if you don't want to and that's
that's your prerogative so you know i
want it to be voluntary um
and and the great thing about that too
is if you say no and you leave crowd
health the money in your account is
still your money so we give that money
back to you
it doesn't go into an insurance company
and you never get to see it again it's
actually your money it's sitting in your
account and when you leave we we take an
account closing fee but anything above
that it's yours
okay um
so well so where does bitcoin come into
it you're putting in 175 dollars a month
um
dollars into an account and then what
and then um if you're a part of our
bitcoin crowd um what do we have a group
of just bitcoiners
who you will be funding other bitcoiners
health expenses um and so um
two cool parts of this one is if you're
a part of that crowd of the 175 bucks
that goes in
75
or a little less than 75 percent is put
into bitcoin so we just announced that's
a bit
a partnership with swan bitcoin um we
put it into swan
and then you you still have a little bit
of cash in your account so because we
don't want you to sell your bitcoin um
so you have cash in your account you use
that if i do crowdfunding and if at any
point you don't have any cash left in
your
your account then you have an option you
can either sell your bitcoin or you can
put a little bit more cash into your
account what we want people to do is put
a little bit more cash in your account
and leave your bitcoin there especially
at 22 000 or whatever it's at today
right um and so in essence what you're
doing is you're putting together your
own little risk pool and it's full of
bitcoin so if you leave and bitcoin goes
from 20 000
to 400 000 like we think it will you get
all of that upside
um all of that appreciation of that
bitcoin is yours um it's not ours you
know health insurance companies will
take your money and they'll invest it
and they get the profit of that
no no you and you're putting it into
bitcoin and all that appreciation of
that bitcoin is yours
so we don't have any inflationary
assets anymore you have bitcoin
and you're you're sharing your expenses
with other bitcoiners um and i was in
miami you know what a few months ago and
as i'm walking around and seeing these
20 000 peoples like these bitcoiners are
young
they are in better shape than the
general population and so that's going
to be the community of people in which
you're going to be helping each other
paying their their their bills um and so
you know it's a really good group of
people to be you know helping out
because they just don't have very high
bills you know it's injury-related bills
like you know running or playing soccer
or whatever it may be sorry football
where you are lei i'm sure um
as opposed to like
diabetes and
obesity and and
cost related to that so you're in a
group of people who are taking their
health care they're taking personal
responsibility over their own health
care which is the group of people that
you want to be involved with um so those
are the two kind of cool components of
what we are doing with bitcoin is you
get to hold some of your money in
bitcoin and you're a part of a crew a
crowd of bitcoiners um and we we think
that's pretty cool
so you're not joining a crowd of
severely overweight people who want to
take no personal responsibility for
anything that they do eating terribly i
think bitcoin is absolutely they're
carnivores right they're carnivores
they're all they're all healthy folks or
most are anyway no seed oils none of
that
right well and it's it's true like i i
mean these bitcoiners are
you know actuarially better off than
than the general population they take
personal responsibility for their own
their own health care you know and i
think that's important too the third
component of a bitcoiners that i think
is a really cool characteristic is
if you have a system in which you think
you're getting screwed
which is our current health care system
we have a a
psychological
component to this is i want to take as
much out of the system as possible right
i want to consume as much because i'm
getting screwed by the system
whereas if you have a system of people
who are bitcoiners and you know that if
you
try to take you know be a leech on the
system it's just impacting your other
bitcoin folks right like you're going to
make better healthcare decisions
if you don't try to to
suck the system out as as much as as you
can right so there's a psychological
impact here too that just the
consumption of resources goes down
because you know you're in a group of of
your people right like this is my tribe
um and we think that has a pretty big
component of reducing health care costs
as well
yeah no that is really interesting and
so you said 75
of what you put in a month goes into
bitcoin yes
that's it that's a that's an interesting
chunk it's not like a small amount so
whatever's left in fear that's
essentially what you would use to fund
other people's procedures yes that's
right and and we've been going on about
a year now um and we have used some 25
of the money that people have put in
for health events um we think the
bitcoin crowd is going to use even less
than that um
and so we think that 25 is the right
number and you know at some point if we
have to you know increase it to 30 or 35
percent you're still putting in you know
65 or 70 percent of bitcoin so we want
kind of all the excess funds to be put
in bitcoin and and um
you know we'll we might have to go up
and down based upon um you know how the
the crew is doing but again there's
another incentive for people to be like
look let's not consume bad health care
um let's let's consume it wisely um and
so we can keep the as much as possible
going into bitcoin and as little as
possible going into into fiat
um you know let me give you just a quick
example of this where
you know we had somebody uh the other
day go and get get labs just their their
annual labs you know you go and get your
blood drawn and they went to a location
where that those labs were 500.
we had we had a location
um like
five minutes it was like two miles away
that we could have gotten the exact same
labs for 50 bucks
so a 90 reduction in a five-minute
car ride right and so
you know i think that bitcoiners are the
ones they're like dude i'm not gonna you
know get scammed by this guy who's gonna
do 500 for something i can get for 50
and so you know if you called up if that
person called us and said hey where can
i get my labs from we could have told
them there was a place two miles away
that you could have gotten your labs
right um and so that's that's those are
the decisions that you can make around
your health care that significantly
impact the cost of of health
it's not a consumption issue generally
it is a price issue so we can find a
really good price
um for you
you know
almost anywhere you live in in the
country at a really high quality doctor
if you just call us and let us know that
you're you're headed that way
so what exactly do you cover then
because um
if it's a 500
uh you have to pay first 500
what if you just want to go see a doctor
i don't know if you have a sore throat
or something like how does that work
yeah so if you want to go see a doctor
for a sore throat well that would
typically be an urgent care visit so you
can go on our app you know you just
head to the app you head urgent care and
within two minutes you'll be able to
talk to a doctor and say hey i have a
sore throat what do you recommend they
can give you a prescription
at the local pharmacy
you know within minutes you know i had a
i had a buddy you know five or six weeks
ago he woke up he didn't feel well he
talked to an urgent care doctor
virtually over our app that urgent care
got doctor get him a six dollar
prescription at the local pharmacy and
within because he thought he had strep
um he did and within 24 hours he felt
much better and he's like hardly even
had to leave his house
and it's like for us the people in our
30s right low
late 20s 30s early 40s like i don't want
to go to a hospital i don't want to go
to a doctor's office i want to do as
much virtually as possible and so you
can talk to a doc anytime you want
virtually and it cost you nothing
that's all part of your membership and
so that's what we're trying to push
people to to is say hey talk to a doc
virtually you don't have to go anywhere
to do that you know we can we can get
you
nine times out of ten what you need
without actually having to go in and see
the doctor and you know what are they
gonna do you know live anyway not not a
whole lot like listen to your heart i
mean
we can tell if our hearts racing or not
what if you need like what if you i
don't know what if like they need to see
you or if you have like a rash on your
body or something like how does that
work
yeah one of our initial one of our
initial uh uh health events over a year
ago was a rash that one of our actually
employees had who was on crowd health
and so she went on urgent care she took
a picture of her the rash she you know
sent the picture to the doctor the
doctor was like it's either a b or c
you know let's try one and if it doesn't
work we're gonna try the next and try
the next and after two visits she got it
figured out um and it was all done
remotely and so if there is and yeah
totally yeah it was a part of her
membership um
and so she didn't pay i don't i don't
think she hardly paid anything as a part
of that maybe just a little bit for
prescriptions but it was a
i think it was you know a 50
prescription or something like that so
it wasn't that big of a deal um even
that fifty dollars like this still blows
my mind because in the uk i don't think
i've ever paid more for a prescription
than like eight pounds i think
prescriptions are eight pounds i think
there's like a cap on it
but we're paying national health
insurance to compensate for that that's
a whole different story on prescriptions
like
our government for some reason won't
allow our medicare to negotiate with the
pharmaceutical companies and so
um you know
we pay in the united states i think two
or three times as much as the next
person pays for all of our our
prescription drugs and it's all the
lobbyists you know on behalf of the
pharmaceutical companies who are you
know giving lots of money to politicians
um you know it is truly like a medical
industrial complex you know it's the
lobbyists are paying the politicians the
politicians are making rules the rules
are impacting our health care and
increasing health care and until you can
you know get rid of the lobbyists um
it's just not gonna not gonna happen so
it's a totally screwed up system over
here
and has um and you're new right
how long have you said yeah one year
yeah so naturally anything that's new
people might feel like there's some risk
there um so have you been able to
genuinely
cover every single
uh
medical issue that
one of your members has brought up
every bill that has been submitted to us
for crowdfunding has been crowdfunded um
and it's been crowdfunded in three days
or less and so
um you know we have a a group of things
on our website that you can go and take
a look that we we will not crowdfund for
so
you know any cosmetic stuff we're not
going to crowdfund for
you know a butt implant like just not
going to happen right we're not doing
that
i hope not yeah and so and you know and
so the other thing is if you have a
pre-existing condition meaning you have
a condition before you join we want you
to be a good member of our community and
and and own your fair share of that and
so you're responsible for it for the
first year
right and then in the second year we'll
fund up to 25 000 of it 50 dollars the
third year and a hundred thousand
dollars a year in the fourth year so if
you have diabetes or something right you
would own the cost associated with that
diabetes in the first year and then we
would start funding it from the
community in the second third and fourth
years
and so we just don't have a lot of
people that have chronic conditions join
but we have a lot of people that have
you know high cholesterol high blood
pressure things like that because
uh the the prescription drugs to take
care of that are are pretty inexpensive
maybe expensive to you but you know it's
it's you know 40 or 50 bucks a month for
high blood pressure and high cholesterol
type of medications and so people are
being like you know what i'm saving
several hundred dollars a month by
joining crowd health i will pay 50 bucks
for my medications knowing that in year
two the the crowd will help out with
that
that's so fascinating so if you become
ill for whatever reason you know and
it's not just a doctor now you know you
you'd like to go see an expert or
whatever it is um i don't know how much
people charge in the us in the uk for
example um if you want to see like i
don't know an expert you'd pay let's say
like
120 pounds an hour to see a consultant
um would do you cover that or not
because it's under that 500
yeah so for any injury or illness the
first 500 bucks is yours um so if you
have you know my i'm going to keep using
my acl tear and i go to an orthopedic
surgeon that orthopedic surgeon is going
to charge you 250 bucks
to see him um and you probably will you
know you'll have a couple visits before
you go so you'll be responsible for that
you'll fund that first 500 and then
anything above that 500 we will go out
and fund from the community um okay and
so that's how that works so yeah you're
responsible for the first 500 bucks of
anything but here's the key to that
right is a lot of people will go to the
er
right and you have no idea what it's
going to cost when you go to the
emergency room you know you can go to
the emergency room and if you have a
five or six or seven thousand dollar
deductible
you're responsible for the first five
six or seven thousand dollars of that
whereas with crowd health if you go to
the er
it's gonna be greater than 500 but
you're going to pay the first 500 and
then we're going to crowdfund the rest
so there is a bit of a peace of mind to
say okay you know i'm not gonna get a
hit up with a ten thousand dollar bill
that i'm gonna have to pay i don't have
ten thousand dollars in my my bank
account this is going to put me bankrupt
and in fact 250 000 families last year
who had health insurance went bankrupt
due to a health care event
and that to me is what we want to get
rid of is get rid of any kind of
bankruptcies related to
health care
and in our year we've had zero so you
know insurance companies 250 000 you
know crowd health zero is so far as is
the scoreboard this looks like a pretty
good scoreboard it again it just blows
my mind like because i
am
somewhat of a libertarian
um so i do think you know it's down to
the individual um
but being from the uk and having the nhs
as something always to fall back on um
when it comes to uh you know medical
expenses is
just so different
you know it's it's shocking it's just
shockingly different
um and i hear a lot of uh
americans actually go down to south
america for um
medical concerns
yeah no and and i've i've heard that as
well i mean i think the
the the bottom line of this is if you
have a health care event like a really
expensive procedure that you have to
have done
we will find you a place that can do it
at a reasonable price you know we had a
guy uh you know a couple months ago
maybe three months ago who had a health
a heart problem in
wisconsin
and his local hospital told him he was
they would do the procedure for eighty
three thousand dollars we found him a
hospital in the united states with a
really good surgeon for twenty thousand
dollars
okay so saved 75 percent
he paid the first 500 we crowdfunded the
remaining
500 and in addition to that he was in
wisconsin his doctor was in oklahoma we
put him him and his wife two first-class
tickets to oklahoma
covered the flights the nicest hotel in
oklahoma city which was a you know four
and a half star hotel um for three
nights paid for all of his food and
still saved i think it was like 55 000
or something like that um versus you
know what his local hospital um
was going to charge him so that's the
price discrepancies that you can find in
our in our country which is is sad i
mean oklahoma city and wisconsin are
only a thousand miles apart and it's you
know 75 percent different that's that's
how screwed up our system is yeah that
is absolutely insane it just blows my
mind um and i'm learning more and more
about this um since you know i work with
mostly americans most my friends are
american now at this point so
um yeah i'm learning more and more about
this and so um i want to go back to the
bitcoin aspect of it for a second so
it's 175 um it's 175 a month and 75
of that roughly goes into bitcoin how
does it go into bitcoin you mentioned
swan like how does that work yeah and so
the the money that is in your account
gets transferred over to swan you open a
swan account when you join us as well um
and so you will have full access to that
that that bitcoin we don't even have
access to it our name's not anywhere on
the account it's all your account it is
a custodian account i know that's not
perfect for all the maximalists out
there but it's one where it's like look
it's it's in your name it's in swan swan
is a you know a
well-respected you know custodian and so
we had to do that for a variety of
reasons um
you know what we're actually working on
is if you get a certain amount of
bitcoin in that swan that you can
actually off board that into a cold
wallet because there's no need for you
to hold you know twenty thousand dollars
worth of bitcoin and in swan like that
that doesn't have
the impact that that we need it to have
we need a thousand or two thousand
dollars so we're going to try to figure
out how to off board that onto a cold
wallet that you know then you have the
keys to that um and so we're working on
that right now but
in essence what happens is is you're
going to join crowd health today
and after uh the first four months it's
it's all cash
the fifth month it's 75 bitcoin 25
dollars and and there thereafter so
that's that's the way that that works
so you actually have two counts that you
set up when you join us a bank account
and a swan account um
so
i'm gonna leave um all the information
in the description guys so if you do
wanna join crowdhealth i'm gonna leave
that all for you in the description um
after the conversation
um so
if they do want to join by the way just
it's it's join crowdhealth.com
leia and if you do slash leia there's a
special promo code for anybody who
is listening to this
so make sure you put leia l-a-y-a-h and
as a promo code and you'll get that that
special promo what is the special
primary it's 99 bucks as opposed to that
175 for six months
so
you get a significant reduction off of
of what you're paying and and here's why
we're doing that is what we've found is
when people join
they have almost no health events for
the first three to six months
especially the bitcoiners that we've
seen these are healthy people they're
coming in and they want to use our
virtual
docs which don't cost the community
anything we pay for that we pay 100 for
that and so the costs are just so low
over that first six months that we're
we're reducing the cost um for for all
that your listeners
and um so
use leia as your promo code
and so you and if whatever reason people
want to leave and you know they say
they've every month they're putting in
175 or 99 or whatever it is every single
month and say they want to leave um they
get that money back basically any money
that they haven't used for crowdfunding
so let's just say that i've been around
for 10 months and i have you know
fifteen hundred dollars in my account
and i've used three hundred dollars of
it for crowd funding which means i have
twelve hundred dollars left
um crowd health takes a 250 dollar close
fee because we have to shut down your
accounts and all that kind of stuff and
then you take the remaining
so i don't know what i don't remember
exactly what the math is but in that
situation you would take a thousand
bucks back with you and we would we
would wire it back to your your personal
account um if you yeah for any of the
money that you haven't used for
crowdfunding so that's one of the huge
benefits of this it's not like you're
just throwing money away it's still
yours you still have access to it and
total control over it
yeah that is one of the most attractive
things about it because what freaks me
out about the u.s healthcare system is
is it some in some ways cheaper to just
not
get healthcare because like if you're
paying a thousand dollars a month right
for like two years
twenty four thousand dollars and then
you have this one health scare
or whatever it is and you know
you have to pay for it i mean
yeah it's sort of cheaper to not do it
we have 30 million americans that don't
have health insurance right and so
they have found and it's a lot of people
who are our age right late 20s to early
40s and they're saying hey uh you know
if i get hurt i'll figure it out
but i don't want to pay
you know 500 if you go to healthcare.gov
it's 400 bucks and then you have a 4 000
deductible
so i'm paying
4 800
plus i have to pay the next 4 000 it's
like 10 grand
so if i have any ill injury or illness
under 10 grand i'm better off being
uninsured and so i'm just going to take
the risk
yeah
yeah for us it's like you're putting
money into your account every month and
yes you're helping the the group um with
some of their big expenses but you're
also going to be helped with some of
your big expenses right we'll crowdfund
that we'll help you crowdfund that so i
mean i think it's a perfect scenario for
folks in their you know 20 lake 20s 30s
40s um
and you know we have people having
babies with us i think we have 10 or 12
babies that are gonna be born here over
the next five or six months so it's good
for that too
um it's just i think a great great
opportunity for folks like
like us if you're in the states i'd get
you to sign up um but our average age is
in the mid 30s so okay that is the
average age it's something like 36 or 37
is the last time that i that i when i
looked
and something i wanted to ask you which
i i forgot um so it's that 500 um
premium that obviously you have to pay
um but say for whatever reason you
wanted to go see a specialist in a
certain area not just a doctor but an
actual consultant
um
would you be able to direct to a
consultant that would pay a lower cost
that will charge lower sure yeah yeah
for sure and we and we have
specialists internally
um you know a neuro specialist a cancer
specialist those kind of specialists
that it's we
outsource it to another company but that
is a part of um if you were to come down
with cancer today
we we have people wherever the wood is
you don't have any wood yeah that's what
we say in england
oh we say touch wood touchwood yeah
knock on wood
um
we we can give you resources but again
even the cost of those resources to walk
you through cancer treatment that
consultant
that is all crowdfunded so you know
you're still if you get cancer today
you're paying 500 bucks we're gonna
crowdfund the rest of of that for you um
and again we don't guarantee that we're
gonna be able to crowdfund it but so far
you know over hundreds of bills we've
been able to crowdfund every single one
so um we don't promise that we'll get it
crowdfunded for you but we're we're
pretty darn good at it
and you never touch the bitcoin it the
the money comes out of so if somebody
needs to say 50 that would come out of
the 175.
okay got it yeah we never touched the
bitcoin we don't have access to it we
don't see it it's yours um and so we
don't we don't uh we don't we can't
touch the bitcoin
yeah no i listen i think it's really
fascinating um you know like i said i've
been doing a lot of research on the
medical industry in the us at the moment
and uh yeah it's been um a learning
curve as a british person it's been
fascinating um so if people do want to
join crowdhealth as their medical
insurance and medical cover um you know
how can they stay up to date how can
they follow you obviously like i
mentioned i'm gonna leave a link in the
description below um but you know how
can they get involved
yeah and just to clarify once we're not
health insurance so um we are an
alternative way to pay for your health
care join crowdhealth.com
leia
and that's you know leia's personal
landing page there so you'll have find
all the information there
join crowdhealth on twitter or
schoonoverandy is my twitter twitter
account so um you can follow me there
too
you
we usually put all of our news out on
twitter first given that's where our
bitcoin crowd is um most of the time uh
so you'll if you follow crowdhealth or
schoon over andy you'll you'll get the
latest
that's great andy i want to thank you so
much for coming on um do you have any
last final thoughts you want to share
with us about bitcoin and you know
really having a form of medical cover
which is just totally outside of the
government yeah i mean if you think if
you really want self-sovereignty you
want to take control of your money
clearly we're all into bitcoin um i got
a significant amount of my worth in
bitcoin and if you don't want the the
government uh you know telling you what
to do with your money i don't think you
want the government telling you what to
do with your body and so
um you know if you truly want to be self
self sovereign you know sovereign
individual then come on over to us and
you can choose uh what healthcare you
know you want and don't want
so we'd love for you all to join us
andy thank you so much for speaking with
me it's so interesting i love to hear um
you know different people and how
they're sort of um involving bitcoin and
whatever they're creating um so thank
you so much for coming on andy thanks
leo see you
yeah absolutely and guys please don't
forget to hit the like button and hit
the subscribe button so you never miss a
video and we will see you all next week
bye bye
the leia high plan show